a Middle School District Board of adults
made the decision to feature an event to
hyper-sexualize young children do you
want to know that the word that defines
that it's groomer
[Music]
well the Attorney General United States
mayor Garland has ordered federal agents
to investigate parents who dare to
complain about their school boards in
particular parents are no longer allowed
to say anything when creepy adults
sexualize their children in San Diego
County California one mother called
Brittany Mayer noticed that her school
board was supposed to be educating her
children had instead invited them to a
quote family-friendly drag Show
sponsored by a San Francisco gender
reassignment surgery center and a
nightclub
I want to make it really clear that this
is not a an isolated incident this is
coming to every school Across the Nation
and if you think that it's just going to
stay in California you're dead wrong
this is coming everywhere we need to now
use Brave words and words with meaning
and call it like it is
the the event is sponsored by a sex
change Surgical Center in San Francisco
which I have no idea how or why they're
involved in this
but we want answers as to why this was
approved
[Music]
it is a case that's getting national
attention as the Encinitas Union School
District finds a claim that its yoga
classes are religious
superintendent Timothy Baird implemented
the program last year with a 533
thousand dollar Grant from the KP Joyce
Foundation an organization with Hindu
roots that promotes yoga in schools
[Music]
School leaders in Encinitas went on a
luxury Retreat there are signs all over
the entrance to the school asking
parents to donate and that's just one
reason why the schedule of this
Leadership Retreat has them so upset
this has nothing to do with being
anti-gay it has nothing to do with being
right or left this has everything to do
with morality as parents
[Music]